we're saying in the next 15 years will
cut child to death in half that took 25
years to cut it in half before and this
would be down to one in 40 dying before
the age of five from one in 20 from
others we say we'll cut it by two-thirds
and you have to have antibiotics you
have to be able to stop bleeding some
cases you even have to do c-sections so
that's very much a delivery thing that
the maternal part is less about
breakthroughs and more about the quality
of the health systems and instead of
delivering at home delivering in a
health facility how about farming well
farming is another program we've been in
a lot funding the research centers that
come up with the better wheat seeds corn
seeds rice seeds that's kind of a global
public good no single country gets all
the benefit everyone in countries too
and yet it's often underfunded still the
scientists I've seen how to make seeds
that deal with less water deal with heat
yield more per acre and those are
getting out slowly but surely to the
farmers employers for Africa in
particular we're predicting a fifty
percent increase in productivity and
that'll mean that Africans set up buying
fifty billion dollars of food like it
does today will net be self-sufficient
able to grow as much food as as people
eat on the continent of Africa you think
that by 2030 Africa will be able to feed
itself that's the bat that's the
prediction these investments have to get
made it's kind of ironic that the
continent where over sixty percent of
the people are farmers is buying food
from the United States we're less than
two percent to the people are farmers
you know they are spending their money
to have food be imported and yet they
have lots of land lots of labor
if we can just get that productivity to
be better than they they'll they won't
be spending their money on food from
other countries I think it's fair to say
bill that some people are perplexed by
this notion that bill gates of all
people sees opportunity philanthropic
opportunity in banking how is banking
going to change the lives of poor people
15 years from now well banking is is
more fundamental than I realized when
you you know have a medical expense that
you don't expect when you need to pay
for a funeral or a school fee the idea
that you have to save up to buy seeds at
the start of the planting season and
fertilizer and you only get the payment
for that at the end of the season and if
the weather's been bad some you're sure
you'll get very little it's very hard to
tide yourself over if you see an
opportunity and there have been attempts
microfinance groups cooperatives but the
transaction fees were always too high so
until we got to the digital approach
where we avoid currency and bank tellers
and complex ATM machines and we turn
your cell phone just by itself into a
debit card that you can transfer money
to a relative out in the rural areas to
the shop you can have a special savings
plan for say a farmer until we get those
services down with very little fees on
to the the cellphone in digital mode
then banking will only be for those who
are better off what about education
what's your big bet there well education
is is fundamental so if you can fix
education then the whole productivity of
a whole society goes up kids when they
go into class may have no experience of
looking at letters and words or doing
simple math problems now with the beauty
of online technology parent will be able
to expose the kid to letters and numbers
and little games to try things out the
software will get a sense of what the
level of knowledge is and make
in pristine and challenging give that
kid a sense of progress so the fact that
not only will we have classroom learning
but we'll have all this great software
delivered through the phone or tablet
different screen sizes connected to that
mobile network which connects to the
Internet the quality of that software
including the free forms of it 15 years
from now will be so dramatically good
that as you go through life and any
teacher can go in and see what you've
been good at what what stuff for you it
makes education way more productive
particularly for motivated students
they'll be not no longer limited by the
material in the classroom